[Musique]
vibrante les cochons parlent à longueur
de journée un langage pour le moins
coloré dans la fiction comme dans la
réalité
et si nous parvenions à décrypter ces
grognements une idée pas si farfelue car
pour l'équipe du projet soundwell 1
vaut 1000 mots le projet réunit des
spécialistes du comportement animal d'un
peu partout en Europe
leur but mieux comprendre le bien-être
des cochons
leur méthode décortiquaient les émotions
de ses bêtes à partir de leur grognement
pendant une dizaine d'années les
chercheurs ont enregistré les sons émis
par plus de 400 cochons pour chaque
enregistrement ils ont associé une
émotion selon le contexte et les
battements de cœur des bêtes certaines
émotions plus positives comme lorsque
les cochons se nourrissent ou courent
librement et d'autres plus négatives que
lorsqu'ils se battent ou sont isolés
l'équipe a collecté près de 7500
cristins une banque de données colossale
à analyser et c'est ici que
l'intelligence artificielle entre en jeu
un algorithme est parvenu à reconnaître
pour chaque émotion les caractéristiques
acoustiques du grognement
par exemple les émotions positives sont
associées à des sons plus courts dont
l'amplitude varie peu
pour les émotions négatives les cris
sont généralement plus longs et aiguës
avec leur algorithme les chercheurs
souhaitent maintenant développer une
application de traduction des
grognements en temps réel
une telle application permettrait aux
éleveurs d'adapter leurs pratiques selon
l'état de bien-être ou de détresse de
leur cochon
le projet soundwell les centres voire un
univers de possibilités
utilisez l'intelligence artificielle
pour comprendre le langage des animaux
avoir accès à leurs états d'âme
face aux conséquences de l'élevage
intensif commercial l'étude des émotions
animales et d'ailleurs de plus en plus
répandue
[Musique]
la santé des bêtes n'est plus seulement
définie par leur état physique mais
aussi psychologique
et sur le sujet les cochons en ont
encore long à nous dire
[Musique]